this morning actress amber hurd returns
to the witness stand in a defamation
lawsuit against her ex-husband that
would be johnny depp heard testified
yesterday that depp physically abused
her in the marriage in his testimony
depp said that he was the abuse victim
depp's 50 million lawsuit claims heard
ruined his acting career after she wrote
an op-ed article for the washington post
and described herself as a domestic
abuse survivor now heard is now
countersuing debt for 100 million
dollars carter evans has the story and
we have to warn you this is really
cringy messy stuff heard's testimony
includes graphic accounts of alleged
abuse
at some point uh johnny whacks me in the
face
taking her turn on the witness stand
amber heard didn't hold back about the
abuse she says she took from ex-husband
johnny depp he backhands me i remember
kind of just
feeling like my lip went into my teeth
and it got a little blood on the wall
the 36 year old at times choking back
tears says the first time deb hit her
was in 2012. slapped me across the face
i knew it was wrong and i knew that i
had to leave him
and that's what broke my heart
because i didn't want to leave him
heard says she and deb fell in love in
2011 but she says that romance quickly
evolved into a jealous rage
depp testified earlier in the trial that
he never hit his wife but heard's lawyer
showed the jury a photo of a bruise on
her arm she sent to her mother he
grabbed me by the arm and he kind of
just held me on the floor screaming at
me at one point during a drug-induced
rage she says depp sexually assaulted
her by conducting a body cavity search
he said he was looking for his drugs his
cocaine his coke
he just
just stood there staring at the stupid
light there's going to be many jurors
who could easily find her entirely
credible cbs news legal analyst ricky
clemen says heard's defense may depend
on what others saw
do you think we'll see any other
witnesses on the stand that can
corroborate amber heard story there can
be no doubt that amber heard's lawyers
are going to call corroborating
witnesses without corroboration there
are going to be some jurors who would
simply say well she's a fine actress for
cbs morning's carter evans los angeles
if you've been watching the testimony i
have somebody isn't telling the truth
here and whatever the verdict is when it
comes out i don't know how anybody wins
in this case i don't know how you sort
it out i mean because i don't know
gradations of truth as well but yeah
each calling the other one a liar and
the judge and the jury are going to sort
it out somehow but it's amazing seeing
what johnny depp is willing to admit to
doing yes in his addiction his battle
with with a lot of demons right as
everybody's searching for clarity it
just seems like it's getting more and
more messy
very unpleasant